all right so this is the silent king
what's the name of the bad guy in this
that is it just wasn't Sergio Sergio
okay so it starts off with them fighting
officer you wanted more but Senor I am
giving to the bots okay so in the last
video I was like I'll start going at the
big green pod but and I was just like
Bob just I better see triple more but to
the neck so and holy God because the guy
in this the sir yeah guy has he rolls
the kingdom you know like really meat
and stuff and his big thing is he likes
to spank people waiting you just know
that like somebody out there it's like
this was like fans I always like to see
a goblin probably does watch Adventure
Time oh so fam and Jacob they defeat
them and they decide or Finn decides
he'll be the king and Jake the Queen and
of course yeah gory kidneys a queen
Ethan was not female and pretty much
goes and he can't do anything that
people have to do everything for him and
he gets sick of a doesn't like it and
then when Serbia is attacking with this
friggin hilarious ear army like when I
saw that I like nearly died died because
I I just love weird designs like that
they just crack me up
um and Jake becomes his suit of armor
his disguise which I guess hilarious and
he's nice idea so you know they got done
that like before in our scenarios but
again you getting their mind frame it's
like they wouldn't necessarily think
about those are times and they would
think of it now even though it's prior
with the writers we're doing like oh hey
we should do this give him like a Jake
suit or whatever but I don't know it
seems like the writers mind says very
much reflected in this show of just like
the sporadic Nissen oh yeah this like
thing just sort of
I don't know it just seems very
connected to how just I don't know where
their mindset is to UM and gos wins a
day by clapping in their ears also
hilarious and they put in this fake King
to whisper Dan ya know whisper Dan
that's right to take his place because
they just can't live without a king
every single time they want to he breaks
a rule they think they're gonna get
spanked cuz I guess they're so
traumatized by the spanking King so you
grow up with a way of life the saddest
scene is one that what guy the assistant
is just in there like nothing's even
goin god he's just having like a dream
like this please don't spank you so sad
like that's just wait does I just I'm
off you just fear and the spanking
season where they show like what he did
with all is so funny and be sure and
then from falls like just comes like
haha it's really funny
oh the I say for me the only part where
I saw God Oh touch board you know for an
11 minute cartoon when any oh no a few
seconds boring but is when it is when
the is when the Gallants are like no no
we have to do everything for you it's
you kinda know where it's going and they
like the chewing your food and it's dumb
and I feel like I've seen that before at
least heard it before you know and other
stuff so it's like it's still not okay
it's still traumatizing okay now it's
traumatizing spankings though yes it is
where we think like they're totally okay
with like brushing his teeth and chewing
the food but spankings are too far this
is a weird group of goblins as opposed
to the normal group of goblins but yeah
I think it started off really strong it
and too strong anything with that with
that weird spanking King it seemed to be
hilarious like anything said around him
what's really really funny yeah so I
thought stars try and destroy littles
okay
yeah but you know kind of predictable
you know where it's going but like I
said then when the Army's coming it's
like oh what they gonna do so but I
liked
like I said I like the beginning and
ending uh especially sorry I thought it
was pretty neat concepts because you
know you always want what you can't have
and and who what's the coolest thing
possible on the planet rule no never
that never that but to rule a kingdom to
be you know the top dog and it was
really neat I know it's silly and then
boring I'm so sorry
I just knew where it was always wonder
why you get kicked off of here all the
time
master I don't care
no but it's it's this idea of all
wouldn't it be so cool until you're
actually there and then it's not quite
so cool and that quite well I mean okay
you got no really go ahead what I was
gonna say every we're gonna bring up
spanking I'm not listening no I was
gonna say is that at first you kind of
think that you know like we use that oh
it's not gonna be everything you thought
but I'm like well the rules are so
strange though that is kind of hard to
get behind that mindset but then then
again like I saw some sort of special
like a documentary or something about
like whatever the richest like ten
people in the world or something like
that or like you know and how they live
their lives and stuff like that it's
like some of that's not too far off like
you know just like and at these certain
hotels like you know the way they have
to be treated in the way they have to be
greet if they say something wrong like
all the staff has to know like eighty
different things about this one person
like how they like the door opened or
whatever and it's like yeah so that's
not that far off so MIT maybe it's not
so far-fetched strange is a relative
term I mean strange to you doesn't
necessarily mean it's strange for other
people wait a minute it's Jory and it's
Jory what's going on here Jory's kissing
jewelry I love you know you're the best
okay never do your talk people or what
use it thank us yeah it doesn't matter
it's just gonna look at the cat Nell in
there
okay cameo I'm so pretty mule
yeah up your shot bye that's so
cat that's so cat and yet we keep
calling her a sheep but really he's a
boy yeah he's a very handsome boy do we
ever say the cat's name by the way his
name is Naruto yes after exactly you
think it's better as opposed to the
other Naruto are there other Naruto it's
such a specific name well actually
Naruto is the little piece of fruit on
top of ramen in Japan
oh is it yes oh and it's a swirly thing
a newsie Maki which is narratives last
name also means a swirl spiral that's
much more adorable was a Maki no oh
there you go so Jason talked about the
also know the one thing I can't believe
you guys are failing to mention I guess
for me okay when someone breaks the rule
who gets punished the rule breaker yeah
oh dear King but that's the thing
noticing this he breaks all these rules
and everyone else around him is ready to
be punished
the only thing I could figure with that
is that they were so traumatized from
the last one that when they said hey you
broke a rule he would get angry and you
know spank him you know so maybe that's
just what they were used to and they
were so scarred by it I mean mazes like
years and years or years of putting up
with this so that's because I thought
it's a little weird too but that's the
only connection I could make with that
wait a minute the real you comes out
see that's the segue to the next one I
won't hide it like the other ones that I
do that's no fun happy now you're just
upset cuz I totally blew your theory you
had like this whole thing ready to go
off on a rant and there's just like oh
we know that makes total sense but it
doesn't make sense it makes total sense
yeah mr. C butts everywhere well I
certainly saw him in this one yeah cuz
you wanted to I
can I see pretty naked ladies this one
no no I'm just getting this now so I can
see the next one bye